oh and this morning this is another
thing I was listening to Morning Joe
this morning because I wanted to
see if they had changed their minds
about the polls nope nope now no I'll
admit I'll admit Joe scarber this
morning this sun he was defending
Joe Biden and his age which I mean I
don't know why it's such a big deal that
that people think Joe Biden's old he is
old so is Trump they're both old they're
old why is it such a big
deal oh because they're too old too old
Joe Biden's only a couple months older
than Donald Trump and he can
ride a bike I don't know if that makes a
difference to you or
not but Donald Trump is even putting out
videos of him golfing and acting like he
and seriously they're saying he's the
most athletic president
ever and you should see this gulf swing
you should see that that
cheeseburger gut get in the way of his
golf swing it is the shittiest golf
swing I've ever seen in my
life Joe Biden can ride a
bike I can't even ride a
bike I'm I'm 40 I can't ride a I mean I
I could attempted it wouldn't look very
good and been on a bike in a long
time but yourbody can ride a goddamn
bike and we're worried about him being
too old come on people out of here
Donald Trump's only a few months Young
than Donald Trump he's old too and he's
too old if Joe Biden's too old out
of here now what the polls that they're
freaking out about is that oh my God 60
some percent of people think Joe Biden's
old yes he is old what what the
hell is the deal people in their 20s
okay all right just bear with me here
this is some wild logic it's
going to blow your mind people
in their early 20s
think people in their late 70s and early
80s are old that's how it works
W don't you know this what the are
you worried about they're not gonna be
basing their election based on age folks
they're not they're not electing someone
based on how old they are in this next
election because the two guys that are
going to be one Republican one Democrat
they're months apart in age and one of
them can ride a bike and the other one
can barely pick up a cheeseburger to
devour it so okay yeah I'm I'm over the
old stuff and the media is a bunch of